après avoir testé les jeux les plus
rageant de la planète il revient
aujourd'hui pour vous prouver une fois
de plus qu'il un bateau de skill ok le
malaise on arrête donc à toute
discussion se trouve si on blood the
unjust c'est un petit joueur agents le
principe est très simple c'est plein de
niveaux et on n'a que dix secondes pour
faire chaque niveau les mecs sont des
eaux à faire un joli perdurer en plus
pour casser les couilles
ils ont que 10 secondes pour le faire
quelle bonne idée nouvelle partie je
n'ai pas encore eu l'occasion de le
tester
on va voir si c'est si difficile que ça
iolo mode jeu parce que c'est moi faire
le mode normal
ok premier level hockey s'est passé 2e
level hockey s'est passé 3e le bel où
j'avais enchaîné autant je suis alors
retrouvé dans le vie de merde
ok oh merde ça si on pouvait sauter mon
gars comme on compare à courcy de
malades on peut pas le faire qu'on va
arrêter de se faire rêver au pied c'est
quoi ce piège non pas king crab
l'abricot nazim pas saint louis ghost
roubia samedi l'envol hockey a bataillé
ou suivent
hockey hebdo j'ai compris clac clac clac
et oui ok succès c'est quoi ça tajbakhsh
talence impressionnant franchement on
s'en est jamais aussi aller mater ses
longues mains non hier c'est la totale
ok ça se complique mais rien de panique
en attelage là je paye pour rien là mais
c'est quoi ça attends mon cerveau ibug
commenté sur s'est passé ça mec millet
mais c'est trop on va y aller moi diolot
ok on va y aller en mode 3 kills ou
tranquille où je te plaît ouah ok en
fait ce qui s'est passé ça ça va trop
vite mais qu au nom était tellement loin
mais terry le sueur fuite avec booba
riahi dans son clip suis dedans
oh là là là c'était d'une beauté c'était
d'une bonté à l'agencé apa tard donc je
pense qu'il faut aller là-bas en fait
voilà voilà voilà
d'accord là on descend là faut y aller
vite et on s'en sort tranquillement ça
c'est pas très dur ça merde nyolo n'a
plus le temps
là oui monsieur [ __ ] aucune panique à
avoir
ok lambeaux a indiqué arsenal est hyper
chiant manon oh là là là là là mais quel
ton ami historien au [ __ ] c'est chiant
ça vaut [ __ ] c'est chiant mais c'est
impossible mais c'est impossible à ok
fallu le faire des débuts en fait ok
ryan lochte yunlin claque tu te barres
tu te barres bois ou non mais la hâte en
mairie pour un enfant m'a pris pour théo
ok j'ai compris faut faire clac clac
clac clac au caire bon olalala comment
vous avez vu on à semer la zizanie
j'ai pas entendu ça depuis dix années et
si on annonce à elle et à temps mais là
est là on est chaud bouillant or si les
gages et on y va
voilà tranquillement olala on va compter
sur la chasse est parti j'ai un vote la
chatte
oh là là comment j'ai compris vous a vu
la technique et un interrupteur fait
chier on en fait chier à mais comment tu
vas aller choper l'interrupteur je
comprends pas oh là là alors je ne sais
pas comment j'ai fait je ne sais pas est
ce que c'est la fin du jeu non non moi
faut être précis des ouffia des pics
partout sur les côtés à sable collé la
langue qui est sorti croyez moi c'est
que ça très redoux alors là on va faire
réfléchir
ok bah voilà tout simplement pas le
temps de réfléchir
j'ai compris les gars et il m'a regardé
hockey voila voila c'est un numéro
allez on passe la glace aucun problème
regarder en restant speedrun wisigoths
toc
fac j'ai pas fait exprès je pas je veux
pas faire le mec tu as ça qu'on a que 10
secondes a tendance à l'oublier mais
l'idée rien il faut aller très très vite
un point gagnant à ya quand même des tas
mois à la mecque sans déconner aucun
nouveau aux as et là c'est du vrai sol
au les [ __ ] lorna lawrie temporise
on est bon voilà on est passé au continu
laser on s'en bat les couilles au côté
ok les gars a lâché en train de perdre
ma volonté de gagner par contre j'ai
toujours ma liberté de pensée florent
pagny ce pour tout rentable
un mec c'est chaud faut que je me serve
du bloc comme appui pour le laser mais
c'est impossible
non mais je vous jure ça ne passera
jamais c'est sûr j'en ai marre j'en ai
marre j'ai eu ma chance on pète un câble
comment on passe
ok en fait j'ai compris la télé internet
ça c'est ça faut juste se baisser comme
ça et blogs laser et on peut passer
[ __ ] qu'est-ce que j'étais content
vous étiez là les gars calmez vous y
voilà their homes ont gagné plus de la
zac en boîte de nuit en boîte de nuit
faisait remarquer à welch et 90 jaurès
écoles pour le mot ça part en couilles
ok on passa t alors il se passe quoi là
assez horrible celui-là il est horrible
selon m faut il appuyer sur le bouton
qui alla ensuite ce bar & co
gros gadget au cou oh oh oui oh oui oh
oui oh oui
est-ce que c'est là parce que sa fin et
je trouvais les bots you tube games
s'est pas ok c'est nouveau au ciel ça me
plaît pas ça donne le mail et
synchronise parfaitement de manière ad
synchroniser son cerveau d'accor s'est
fait mal en fac ollioules aux modes de
jeu le mode activé c'est tellement elle
achète vos gars très simple très très
simplement je n'arrive même plus à
parler maïté mon show you lost the beach
hockey onomique non mais t'es sérieux là
il faut et qu'il faut faire pour qu'ils
tombent dans le vide en mêlée maïté
s'arrête plus quoi mais comment le blog
qui doit tomber dans le vide mais
comment je fais pour l'attirer dans
levine ah bah voilà ok je compris faut
que je leur amène bien maintenant et n'a
pas suffi à bata au kérosène pour s'y
attend c'est dur vous avez compris ou
pas en fait plus foule bloquer la nuit
je vais le chercher et là faut que je
trace le film poursuit le papa oui oui
où j'ai dit oui mon gars si on arrive au
bout de ce jeu c'est tellement un truc
de ouf
allez mon gars sympa ça passe j'ai put
un vrai ça soit un peu musclé attention
olala comment je suis appuyé mon gars
calmez vous fucking kahn garde au
le mec ça ne s'arrêtera jamais juste de
finir ce jeu de me la péter laissez-moi
olaf à romao craint rien ni personne
c'est un truc de malade toi comment on
fait là non mais comment tu fais là à
mon avis il faut le mener en bourrique
et ensuite au nom yes yes à noosa temps
plus durs les gens peuvent plus prélever
le level qu il attend très flou et je
comprends plus quoi faire je comprends
plus rien non mais mexès et là tu peux
plus là j'y arrive plus là c'est mon
cerveau il à zilina enfin il faut que
tous les cas si quelqu'un comprend
quelque chose qu'il avec la vidéo voilà
il y aura aucun aucun lag qu'on va y
arriver mais combien mais si on y arrive
on a les masters youtube
c'est la fin on a terminé le jeu non
abonnez vous